today's video is very simple today we
are answering the web's
most asked questions about architects
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're turning our head towards
google and finding out what some of the
biggest questions are
about architects and architecture in
2021
so let's not waste any time and get
straight into it let's start off with
what do architects
do um well we design either houses or
commercial properties
and we basically provide assistance from
the start to the finish
that's the simplest way i can really
answer it we're a creative
bunch of people that utilizes a whole
bunch of different skill sets
guess where the jack of all trades we're
able to design creatively but we're also
able to solve very complex problems at
the same time so yeah that's kind of
what we do
what do architects wear so i guess
architects can wear absolutely anything
it's becoming more and more of a trend
to push away from
the formal suits and collared shirts and
move more just to your casual jeans and
t-shirt
personally i still like to wear an
actual dress shirt and a suit every now
and again i try to stay away from the
casual approach
i do have a lot more higher end clients
so they don't really enjoy you coming to
their home
or their business just dressed very
casually especially being a young
architect
you get stereotypes all the time so you
try and stick to
the stereotypical architect of a suit
still
what the architect earn architects can
earn anything really
and it depends how good you are as an
architect i guess
from a personal point architects can
earn anywhere from
40 000 which is minimum wage all the way
up to half a million
if not even more depending if you run
your own firm it's
yeah it's a very broad spectrum i guess
the average architect
in australia earns anywhere where the
average salary is so i'd say that's
about
seventy thousand dollars um but yeah
architects can earn
much much more than that if they're good
at their job and even more than that if
they are running their own practice what
do architects
charge um easy
architects charge either on an hourly
basis or on a percentage fee
so you can charge on a percentage be it
two three four percent of the total
value of construction
so if you have a million dollar project
and you want to charge four percent for
your services
your fee will be forty thousand dollars
it's kind of simple when you do a
percentage
alternatively you can have a fixed fee
so somebody can come up to you and go i
have a million dollar project
and you know from experience that you're
gonna charge anywhere from that
three to four to five percent so you
just give them the fixed upfront costs
of 40 grand
and hopefully all goes well you make the
money if not there are projects where
you lose some money but at the end of
the day you win some you lose some okay
moving on to the next question
how do architects design houses
um i guess through skill practice
experience um yeah we design houses
starting from the very basics of
architecture
solar passive design usually plays a big
principle in it
you want to really design a house based
around what the client wants and their
needs
and then work around them so it is a
very formal
kind of dance between you and your
client and understanding their wants
their needs how they live how they move
and then designing around that and then
only adding the principles of
architecture and construction
into that to actually make it feasible
so we are also i guess restricted by
regulations and the government
authorities so there are some
legal aspects to designing houses that
most people aren't aware of
but at the end of the day yeah it really
is about designing for that individual
person how do architects get
client that is probably the hardest
question anybody can ask an architect
it is a challenge getting clients
i guess can come down to a magnitude of
different things you can go out you can
search the web but you can let a box
drop if you want to do it old school
i guess for me it's all about social
media content creation it's all about
putting yourself out there on the
internet and making sure you rank higher
in google
so when somebody types in local
architect or perth architect or albany
architect or whatever they want to type
in
i'm going to rank pretty high up or my
business is going to rank pretty high up
so for me again it's using social media
and using
my skills as an entrepreneur and
everything i've developed over the past
to be able to bring up
all my architectural skills at the same
time for other people word of mouth
works really well if you start off in a
small community
you can work do one really good job word
of mouth gets you the next job
and so on and so on i know plenty of
business owners who have never spent a
cent on social media advertising they've
literally just gotten all their work
from word of mouth so there is always
that option okay
next question when do architects
get paid um it depends if you work for a
firm or if you work for yourself
if you work for a firm whatever your pay
roster is i guess once a week once
fortnight once a month
it's pretty normal um if you're running
your own company if you're running your
own projects
you usually get paid in stages when a
stage finishes so you'll do sketch
design where it's just the conceptual
ideas you'll get paid for that
you'll move on to the drawings for the
council you'll submit it you'll get paid
you move on to the next stage which is
usually construction to really dumb it
down
and then you get paid once those
drawings are done that's
generally the principles of how
architects get paid in their own
business it's
you finish a stage you get paid when do
architects retire
uh i don't know i guess never
architecture is one of those professions
that you
can work to your 90 you can work to your
100.
i guess you just kind of sit at a desk
most days and
walk out the site every now and again so
you have that ability to work as long as
you physically can
if you have to i guess some architects
will retire
as soon as they make enough money to
retire others will do it forever because
they're just so passionate about it
i guess it's a very very difficult
question to answer moving on to what
architects
what architects make the most money
simple the architects that own their own
practice
architects usually make the most money
running their own businesses as long as
they're successful
alternatively the best paid architects
are partners in the company the ones
that contribute the most
so if you're working your way up the
corporate ladder same as lawyers same as
accountants
same as everything else architecture is
very similar you work your way up
through associates directors partners
things like that so
the higher up in the company are the
more money you make at the start
not so great but that's expected most
graduates of architecture make
very little most graduates of any real
profession make very little
so once you're able to move up in the
company you will make more money
and eventually make the most once you're
at the top what architects do on a daily
basis um i actually made a video
day in the life of an architect so i'll
link that down below if i remember
otherwise just search day in the life
david thomas
and you will find what an architect does
every single day
basically what architects can do
terrible english but what architects can
do is a
variety of different things i guess
as an architect you can design houses
you can design commercial properties
you can render 3d imagery you can do 3d
videography
you can do content creation you can do
architectural photography you can get
into video game design
you can get into cinema design there's
so much you can do as an architect
because your skills are so transferable
you learn so so much at university and
then you take those skills and you learn
even more when you get into the
workplace so
there's many architects that are working
in hollywood there's many more that are
working for
some of the biggest gaming corporations
in the world as well so you can
literally do almost anything as an
architect and that goes back to the jack
of all trades as i spoke before
moving on to the next category and the
last category i guess for today is
can architects be rich yeah of course
you can be rich in any profession as
long as you are good at your profession
or able to start your own business i
think personally speaking
by providing value to your company and
by providing
knowledge and things that they can't
actually do without you you're able to
do a lot better than anybody else
so if you're looking to get rich as an
architect that's probably the best way
but generally speaking architects don't
make a lot of money
unless they are pushing the boundaries
can architects certify documents
depends on documents there's some we can
there's some we can't
there's random things we can and there's
random things we can't so that's
you gotta be a bit more specific with
that one can architects work from home
absolutely cover 19 really showed us
that almost anybody can work from home
as long as we have the right tools which
we've developed architects i think can
work remotely they can work from home
they can work
anywhere around the world if they want
to it's a really
easy business to run well that's a lie
it's a very difficult business to run
it's a very easy profession to do as
long as you have the
tools so if you have a laptop that's
powerful enough to run all your software
you can definitely work from home that
same laptop can be used anywhere around
the world can architects sign
stat decks uh in australia i believe yes
we can
can architects have tattoos again in
australia it's a discrimination thing so
you can definitely have tattoos in the
workplace
your employee may ask you to cover it up
or not but you can't not hire somebody
because they have tattoos that's just
unethical can architects do interior
design
yes some some not it's
it is not something that we're
specifically trained at it's something
that
you get experience as you get better and
as you get older and the more time you
put into it so if you want to do
interior architecture
that's a completely separate course at
university in australia
but architects do predominantly do a lot
of interior design work as well can
architects make millions can architects
become millionaires
it seems to be a very big question about
the arctic profession seems like people
just want to get rich in architecture
like i mentioned before yes you can get
rich but you can get rich in any single
field whatsoever like you don't have to
be an architect to be rich you don't
have to be a lawyer to be rich you don't
have to be a doctor to be rich
i know people that are social media
influences and have more money than some
doctors i know
so it's really honestly about being the
best at your role
and just being driven enough to be able
to be successful
if you're going to sit back on your butt
all day and just cruise through you're
not going to be successful no matter
what you do
so if you want to be successful you have
to go out and actually
do the work otherwise there's just
genuinely no other way
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching today we
answered some of google's
most asked questions in regards to
architects i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below it is
february so 28 videos in 28 days
is almost coming to an end i hope you
enjoyed the series
because we are still a couple days away
from the end i will see you
tomorrow